hello welcome to our software
development webinar series we've got
that link to today's materials in the
chat area of your control panel if you
want to take a look and download those
now it'll be fine for you to follow
along as Kevin presents today or simply
keep those for your reference for after
the webinar today is the first of three
scheduled webinars that kick off this
new series and we anticipate announcing
additional webinar dates with more
topics in the near future later on in
this session you'll be invited to rate a
list of topics that you'd like to see at
future events we welcome your
suggestions so thanks again for joining
us I am very pleased to welcome today's
presenter Kevin Daley Wolfram software
developer and a Wolfram u certified
instructor Kevin is one of our in-house
experts on parallel computing in the
Wolfram language he has worked in
academia and with Mathematica and the
Wolfram language since version 5 his
presentations today will talk about
optimization on a single kernel
parallelization fundamentals from
multiple kernels and distributed
parallelization for cluster environments
we'll be sharing some online resources
and links with you along the way to
guide you as you become more familiar
with parallel computing in the Wolfram
language and will save some time to
respond to your questions well thank you
Jaime for that introduction on this part
of the webinar series and it does look
like we have a pretty good split between
those who have never used parallel
computation and those who have written
their own code to be run in parallel so
I will try to bring everyone together on
this topic the talk is actually
organized into three parts as Jaime
explained so the first part I think
everyone will find a benefit even if
you're a longtime user of the Wolfram
language you might see some tricks for
speeding up your code even just using a
single kernel and throughout the talk
I'll make sure we're all on the same
page I'll define some terms that we can
all sort of agree on at least for the
duration of this talk which will
hopefully avoid some confusion
so without further ado I'll start with
this section on optimizing on a single
kernel so before we ramp up to using a
distributed say cluster system if your
individual kernel processes are running
slow to begin with you won't get as much
benefit if you distribute those slower
computations to a distributed cluster
environment so if we can first optimize
what these single processes are doing
then they'll run even in a more
efficient manner using multiple kernels
so I'll explain in this section the
differences between using do map table
and if you're not familiar with packed
arrays
I'll introduce those I'll show why list
ability is really the way to go in using
kernels and I will also mention compile
if you really want to squeeze out all of
the available computation in a numeric
function then compile might be
worthwhile and in general a lot of the
topics I'll be covering today are not
exclusive to the Wolfram language when
you start to work in parallel you have
to start thinking in parallel that
involves memory management and other
considerations when working with just a
single kernel the main trade-offs that
you'll have to deal with is between
speed and memory oftentimes you can
trade one for the other so let's jump
right into a property in the Wolfram
language of its many functions which is
list ability so throughout the talk you
will see some hyperlinks to internal
documentation or external sources you
can just click on these bolded words to
bring up the documentation if you need
if anything is unfamiliar also please
send a question to the panel to see if
they can pass it on to me so list of
Bill functions what
this means is they automatically thread
over lists I think everyone is familiar
with the list syntax in the Wolfram
language so if I go ahead and evaluate
this function you see that the list of
ABC is now distributed over the log
function you still have the list format
as the output but it's automatically
basically distributed this structure
another nice thing about list ability is
if you are dealing with arrays or
vectors basically lists or lists of
lists they will automatically thread
over compatible dimensions if you want
to add a single term to a list those
single elements are replicated as needed
and so you still get this nice element
wise addition so and if you use more
complicated functions such as say this
hyper geometric function it normally
does not take or at least in its syntax
if you looked this up it would not
normally take a list as an argument
however it does have the listable
attribute and so if I just use the first
argument as a list it'll automatically
distribute over the hyper geometric
function according to that listed
parameter so this is basically how list
ability works now let's explain which
functions are listed it's basically the
numeric functions so if we go ahead and
basically query the Wolfram language
using the Wolfram language we can
basically get a sense of how many
listable functions there actually are
and so you'll see that all numeric
functions are listed but there are still
a number of functions that are non
numeric the only exceptions to numeric
functions that aren't list of all are
sort of special ones like Max and min
but otherwise if you're working with
sine cosine any of those types of
functions you be familiar with in a math
course they're all lists of all and if
you want to see an even more extensive
list of these basically 300 functions
excluding the numeric ones there is
still
a number of functions that are list of
all but I won't go into any of these
details you can sort of explore those at
your leisure so list ability is really
the way to go but it's not the only way
to go in the Wolfram language there's
many different programming paradigms so
we do support procedural programming
even though we do recommend the
functional approach which I'll explain
using the map function below or you can
use constructor functions like table
which help construct arrays so let's go
through these strengths and weaknesses
of these different approaches and I'll
show you based on some repeated timings
of simple operations which ones are the
most efficient in terms of speed so I'll
start by defining just a simple list of
real numbers from - a thousand to a
thousand just to give us something to
work with now if you notice here I am in
the procedural section actually all
sections I do use a do loop just because
I am basically repeating the same
operation a thousand times in each case
just to sort of beef up the amount of
time it takes to run these calculations
so it gives a easier comparison between
each method so starting with the
procedural which I'm gonna go ahead and
evaluate all of these just to get them
running while I talk so what we are
doing in a procedural way if you've ever
used a non functional language before
you basically have to define an array
structure to hold your results and then
you simply iterate over those results so
in this case I'm simply adding the list
to itself and so in this case the
average time was about 4.6 seconds doing
it in a procedural approach and you see
table has already returned the answer so
the syntax of table is very similar to
the do loop except that when you iterate
it actually creates you don't have to
create a holding structure for the
result it creates it automatically and
so you see you've already shaved off a
few orders of magnitude
in terms of time now this is kind of a
more verbose way of writing things we
are adding the two or basically taking a
part of the array and adding it to
itself but there's actually a slightly
more efficient way of using table where
you literally iterate over the array of
elements themselves and the in this case
the I variable just stands as the
placeholder for each element in that
array and it didn't you'll see that this
is actually a very efficient way to do
things and I'll explain later as to why
that works so a functional approach to
doing these sort of array operations
could be the map function mapping is a
very common thing to do
inside the Wolfram language and other
functional languages so if you're not
familiar with this sort of pure
functional notation it's just using the
slot function to indicate where you want
to make the substitution and you see I'm
simply doing the same operations as I've
done before adding the two elements
together and I'm mapping this operation
over all elements of the list and you
see that the map function is still more
efficient than the procedural approach
it's slightly less efficient than doing
the table iteration so the last thing
really takes advantage of the list
ability attribute that I mentioned
earlier where you can do element wise
addition across these arrays and you see
this is really beat all methods that
I've shown earlier by even another order
of magnitude it doesn't matter if you
are adding the two lists together or
even just doing a simple operation like
multiplying across that entire list so
this is why I mentioned list ability
first because if you can use list
ability it's highly encouraged to do so
that's really where you can get the most
speed benefits so you have to be careful
though because you if you're not careful
you can basically undo those benefits
that I've mentioned previously
so just for comparison this isn't
the an example of using list ability to
your advantage and here's a couple of
ways you might naively program if you're
thinking procedurally or otherwise that
actually undo this benefit we're in this
case we're using table to basically
iterate over something that's already
listable or in the same sense using map
to map a function that's listable over
elements then you see that we've
actually reduced by an order of
magnitude the efficiency of this
calculation so I do see a question that
I'll repeat it says what makes list of
all functions with the this low-level
vectorization faster than mapping I will
actually explain that a little bit later
in this talk it has to do with sort of
auto compiling that happens behind the
scenes but I'll explain that when I
actually get to that point so another
thing to consider if you're using these
sort of looping mechanisms is the
comparison between the actual operation
time versus the overhead involved now
what I mean by that is let's say you're
gonna say a procedural sense just
replacing or putting items into this
list structure but what if each
individual calculation takes a long time
and I represent that sort of time just
by a pause function but you know in
practice these are quite large functions
you might be working with
so again just evaluating all of these
because they might take some time so
let's say I'm doing something that
returns an answer but it takes a long
time to compute and in all of these
cases even procedural using the table
function or map the operation is always
the same but if the majority of the time
is spent in calculating the answer as
opposed to putting it into this array
structure then it doesn't really matter
which approach you take because the
majority of the time is taken up and
calculating each individual element so
if we wait about 10 more seconds you'll
see that the table and map results are
virtually no different
they'll again be 5 seconds and then you
see this sort of fraction of the time is
the overhead and constructing those
results so really if the time is eaten
up based on the calculation itself the
individual step then don't really worry
about the actual technique of doing that
calculation okay so one of the reasons
that under the hood the calculations are
so efficient is because we use a concept
called a packed array in the Wolfram
language many functions that basically
generate large lists are already using
them the downside is that these packed
arrays only accept the data types that
are numeric so basically integers reals
and complex numbers but they have a
double benefit in both memory and speed
of use so just to show you how they work
in memory so I'll explain in the next
slide why this is a packed array but
basic you can see just by looking at the
byte count of a packed array versus an
unpacked array these are identical
structures this one is effectively if I
had written it out by hand it would not
be a packed array and you see that you
save quite a bit of memory if you use a
packed array in terms of speed I'll
evaluate these I'm basically just doing
a multiplication over a packed versus
non packed array this is both element
wise multiplication but you see that the
not packed array is slightly slower
because it doesn't know exactly it has
to basically infer each data type for
each element so one of the ways that we
can access packed arrays it's not
something that is you know hidden or
anything
but basically we're going to load a
special context the developer context
and specifically it will give us access
to some functions here and I'm only
accessing the ones that have the word
packed in them so I just use the needs
function so you access that package and
now I can basically call from packed
array directly instead of having to have
the developer context in front of it so
one of the useful things is to test
whether or not something is a packed
array and so we can use packed array cue
one of our query functions to do so and
the first three here are true examples I
had mentioned range on the previous
slide the reason that this ends up as a
packed array is basically any array
constructor so range constant array
random reals these will automatically
turn themselves into a packed array form
now ones that sort of might be a couple
of gotchas is the table function yes it
constructs an array but it's not
necessarily a numeric array because
table can basically take anything as its
argument and so in that case even though
you are just using integers here it
doesn't know that during the table
construction the other thing is if you
had typed by hand basically created that
array typing each individual element
this is also not a packed array because
the list itself has a very generic
structure and the Wolfram language
doesn't know necessarily that these are
all integers that you've put in and then
the last example I'm actually using an
array generator called random word but
the thing is this generates an array of
strings and string is not a datatype
that's allowed to be a packed array
so if you've se created an array that is
not necessarily packed you can go ahead
and pack it you can actually go back and
forth between these two forms using the
these developer functions so here's an
example of a an array that I typed by
hand so it's not packed but then I can
use the function to packed array to go
ahead and pack it and this works because
they are each integers
there's no mixed datatypes here and so
the Wolfram language can convert this
into a packed array you can go backwards
although I'm not sure why you might want
to do that just using the from packed
array form now what gets kind of tricky
is some operations will unpack
automatically and they'll do this sort
of silently behind the scenes but if you
want to know if unpacking is occurring
then you can set a system option called
packed array options unpack message goes
to true I'm gonna go ahead and turn this
on and then you'll see that some of
these operations will unpack
so this first operation is multiplying a
real number against a packed array of
integers and this is automatically typed
converting all of the integers to real
numbers no unpacking occurs this remains
a packed array now if I do the same
thing using the imaginary number here
the capital I this will actually unpack
and now you see the warning message
occurs that it had to unpack a little
bit to do this and so the reason is this
is a symbolic representation of the
imaginary number but if I also include a
real version here because complex
numbers are basically a set of reals you
see that this actually does not have any
unpacking so these are just sort of
hidden gotcha here another thing is some
operations will automatically convert to
packed form so for example if I join two
lists together one of them I've written
out by hand one of them is already a
packed array
in this case of integers then the join
function will make a packed array of the
combination of the two so there is a
question here what if I have missing in
the array so we can go ahead and test
that so I'm gonna create an array by
hand and then we know that this is not
going to be a packed array because I
created this by hand but let's see what
happens if I try and force this into
being a packed dirty so you see that no
warning was issued or maybe because I
already turned the warning messages off
but you see that this because the
missing is present this is not a array
of a single data type this is a symbolic
expression here even though it does
contain other numeric entries so now
that we understand a little bit more
about how packed arrays are used sort of
under the hood and how you actually have
access to them as well if you want to
squeeze even more numeric computation
out of your results you might consider
using the compile function now the
compile function itself is improving all
the time it was introduced quite a while
ago and we don't have enough timing this
could really be a talk in and of itself
it actually is so I have a link here to
one of our online video conferences
where it actually explains how the
Mathematica compiler works how you can
do code generation and if you're more
interested in that I encourage you to
view that in your own time
so it actually the Wolfram language is
Auto compiling some of the expressions
that you're using without you realizing
it and I'll actually show when it does
that so I'm querying another one of our
system options effectively the compile
options and I'm only looking for I mean
there's more options here than just the
ones I show but I'm only looking for
ones that contain the warned length and
the reason is these are all of the
thresholds that once passed compiling
will happen automatically if possible so
all of the timing examples that I showed
a few slides ago remember that I was
effectively iterating over a list over a
thousand so I was clearly beyond the
threshold of all of these so auto
compilation was actually taking place
during my previous examples and you see
it doesn't take along a very long list
to auto compile a lot of these
thresholds are set at 100 and you can
change these thresholds but they've
basically been chosen such that you
don't notice the transition so what's
nice about Auto compiling is you don't
have to think about it you just use
table use sum or map etc and so long as
you have a long enough list it'll just
happen behind the scenes you'll get a
fast calculation a fast result with yeah
no more thinking involved there are some
sort of warnings though that if you are
trying to utilize this auto compiling it
only works for pure functions remember
the ones that have the hash or are using
the head function and as a demonstration
of this I've defined to user functions
one of which is sort of a generic
expression another one uses the peer
function approach and syntax and if I
just look at a single absolute timing of
these you see that the oh I didn't
expect that result
the user function actually came out
faster
I'm curious it wasn't like that before
but in any case the auto compiling is
occurring for the pure function because
I am basically iterating over a range
that's larger than this threshold so the
other thing to consider is that the you
might have noticed the apply compile
threshold is set to infinity now the
reason this is so is because apply is a
bit more nuanced it only affects list
plus and time so what I mean by that is
if I use the shorthand version of apply
oops I'll actually use plus and I say I
use plus over a range of 10 integers
it'll add all of those integers together
as it replaces the head from list into
plus and so it's only these operations
that are actually auto compiling so keep
that in mind if you want to change that
threshold you really can only use it for
three of these functions so if you want
to go past Auto compiling and actually
write your own sort of compiled code
using this function the syntax is rather
straightforward we use the compile head
we have to declare our variables so in
this case I'm declaring a local variable
or an argument X which is a real
argument and I'm indicating that it's a
one dimensional array so the thing is
when you start to use the compile
function you might get noticed that
there's no actual speed-up of your code
and that's because it still has to call
back to the Wolfram kernel and that's
what we really want to avoid we want
this to actually occur at a much lower
level so to sort of indicate in a
helpful way we can turn on a system
option that tells us whether or not
the compiler has run into any issues so
this is actually a really silly result
I'm actually having compile return a
string but compile only wars with
numeric data types like integers and
reals so this should give a warning and
you see it does you see that the string
could not be compiled and so it
basically has to call back to the kernel
because it doesn't know what to do with
this expression so if you want to
actually see what's happening under the
hood you can load another package called
compiled function tools and once you've
loaded that you get access to this
function called compile print and so you
can actually print your compiled
function and it looks a little bit like
very old C code but the thing to look
for is main evaluate and so again this
is a silly function that basically is
returning a string but compile doesn't
know what to do with strings and so main
evaluate is the callback to the wolfram
kernel to ask for help and these calls
are very costly from these compiled
functions so you want to avoid main
evaluate as much as you can if you see
it appear anywhere then you want to
figure out a way to remove it by
switching to simpler functions or do
loops basically lower-level programming
paradigms
so when you use compile it's not just on
a single core you can do some kind of
fun things with it
on the next slide I'll explain how you
can use multi multiple threads before we
do that you can also get some advantage
by having your compiled functions behave
as if they had the list of lat rebuked
so normally the arguments of your
compiled functions have to match with
the specified inputs so in this case I
have two argument inputs one of them has
to be an unreal of one dimension and
this has to be the second argument is
just a single real number and all I'm
doing is adding the two together and so
if I look at this compiled function you
see I get a complaint now this is on
purpose because in the second argument
I've specified an array but you see in
the definition of the compiled function
it's expecting just a single number now
I could get around this by mapping over
this second array but we can do also
something different we can basically
turn on runtime attribute which is one
of the available options to compile to
allow it to be listable so the arguments
don't change at all I still just specify
that this should be a single real number
the second argument but because I've
turned on the list ability attribute
you'll see these two comparisons here so
in the first case I am literally mapping
over a range of numbers and in the
second case I'm putting in just the
array itself and it's this function is
automatically splitting this up and
running the calculation in an
element-wise manner and so you see we
get not quite a factor of two speed-up
between the two approaches alternatively
I could have actually made this c1 and
it should have a somewhat similar timing
yeah so just to show you that it didn't
matter about the runtime attribute
between c1 and c2 when you're using the
mapping approach
so the next two sections of my talk are
focused on using multiple kernels but
there's a difference between using
multiple kernels and multiple cores or
threads on your local machine and you
can access a multi-threaded calculation
when you use the compiled compile
function so for example you can turn on
the list of all runtime attribute and
you can turn on parallelization so that
goes to true and then it will actually
try and parallel eyes these element-wise
operation at least in this example to
run over multiple threads so if you
recall the previous slide this is
roughly the same time I'm gonna go back
really quickly so we had you know 0.228
versus 0.2 1 3 so only a slight
improvement over mapping now it's sort
of hard to come up with examples that
really show off this type of approach
but I'm going to try that on this lower
half of the slide so here I have sort of
derived a function that has to make a
choice
based on the element that you're
actually running over and so I've made
three versions of this function one of
them takes an array one that expects a
single argument but is has the list of
all attribute turned on and then the
second one has both listable and
parallelization turned on let's see if
there's any difference in these timings
so it's actually not surprising that the
table function did so well because we
know that the table function which is in
this first example is already a
compilable function and actually
performs very well especially when
you're using the syntax of iterating
directly over the array of arguments or
the array itself now it's not so
surprising that when you turned on the
list ability attribute that it didn't
perform as well and that's because you
have to consider the overhead of
splitting up the input list to run in an
element-wise way so if I had come up
with a better toy example we might have
seen some real benefits and turning on
these versions but you do see that when
run over multiple threads there is an
improvement over just running over the
the list of all attribute although this
is still slightly slower than the table
approach now again these are sort of
representative timings in real world
applications you'll most likely see
speed ups because the overhead is sort
of dwarfed in comparison to the actual
calculations
so other considerations and sort of
speeding up your single Colonel
calculations one concept of memoization
where you basically save the value that
you've calculated in order to access it
much quicker at a later time so I'm
gonna go ahead and evaluate these now I
have to find a function here F F which
using again the pause function as a sort
of a representation of a an evaluation
that takes a long time to finish but
does return just a simple result and so
the memorization technique is you see
that I'm using both set delayed to
define the function and then I'm using
just the set function here to basically
recall this value and so you see the
first time that I run this using this
table function it takes about five
seconds because every operation takes
half a second and I'm operating ten
times and then the second time I ask for
it you see it's much faster and that's
because if you actually look at the
saved definitions of this function as
it's been computed it's actually saved
all of their results and so you see that
the first ten results have been
calculated but the the original
definition is still present so if you
were to do F F of eleven for example it
might take a while but it would also
remember that value for future
calculations so this is one of those
trade-offs between memory and speed this
definitely does take more memory to save
the results means small integers like
this it's not a big hit at all but if
your results get more and more complex
you could be consuming much more memory
than you have available so other
considerations for speed versus memory
if you are a bit more limited on memory
than you are on speed then you might
consider a couple of things to offset
the memory usage one of them is a
variable called history length now what
history length is doing I shall just
explain it here if you do a calculation
you notice that it has both input and
output labels on them and you see the
syntax if it looks very similar to
basically setting values and that's
because it is under the hood you can
access these variables at later times so
if I run in of 83 it's actually running
this exact calculation a second time and
so by setting history length equal to 0
or some very small number these in and
out variables will be forgotten they
won't actually be recorded and this can
be very helpful if you're saving large
data structures within your notebook
itself those data structures will
actually be saved in these in-and-out
cells or in and out structures as well
so history length to 0 it only saves it
to the variable and not to these
in-and-out structures another thing you
might want to do is consider moving away
from the notebook interface completely
and so you can do that by making Wolfram
language packages so I'll go ahead and
show we have a very nice package editor
if you go to file new you can then find
the package extension here and that'll
open up a new it looks like the notebook
interface because it still is but these
are very special files in that if you
put in function definitions a little
bigger it types more like a just a
generic text editor in the sense that
spaces and tabs are represented very
nicely here and so if I then save this
file and I'll go ahead and save it to
the desktop
real quick
so if I were to open this with just a
simple text editor you'll see that it
looks very different than if you had
done this opening up a Mathematica
notebook see where did you go there we
are and so you see it has some very nice
special sort of comment sections but
then you see you get basically a one to
one sort of view of this it's just a
simple text file easy to read you can
further edit it in a simple text editor
but again because notebooks have a
tendency to sort of grow in size as you
use them because they save input and
help put cells the package structure
does not do that so if I go ahead and
open up this package again so what I
mean by that is if I do
oops if I insert a new cell that is just
an input cell you can still evaluate
inside this package editor and so you
can still test your code while working
in the package editor but if I save this
and then again open this up in a text
editor you'll see that all of these have
been commented out all of the input
cells and so the only things that
actually stick around is basically
anything that you've put into a code
cell so this is a very handy thing you
get sort of a benefit of both worlds you
get sort of the benefit of using the
front end notebook interface but you
also get the benefit of getting a simple
text file from your results so and with
those simpler text structure files you
can actually run Mathematica scripts so
basically you'll see this notation later
on in my talk as well this indicates
something run from the command line or a
command prompt and so math is the common
way of starting a Mathematica session
but with
- script option you can just run a
simple text file such as the one I
created and it'll just run through each
of the input cells or sorry code cells n
evaluate sort of line by line so this is
another nice way you don't have to start
up the entire Mathematica front-end you
can just run the very simple script
directly through the Wolfram kernel so
just some more considerations if you are
going more towards a software
development approach so other things to
consider is you really have to get down
to the nitty-gritty of knowing how each
of your functions perform if you again
want to squeeze more computation power
out of these so for example you really
just have to know how where the
bottlenecks are and to demonstrate this
again I'm using the pause function as a
representation of a long-running
function and I actually call this slow
function and so let's say I start using
these in production
so as I'm prototyping or building my
code I'll just look at a couple of
absolute timings or even repeated
timings as I've done before and I'll see
that in adding these two functions
together it takes somewhat long time and
so I need to figure out is the
bottleneck in the slow function or is
the bottleneck in this okay function so
then I run each of these individually
and I see that by far the slow function
is taking the majority of the time so
maybe we can improve that slow function
and kind of open up that bottle at the
bottleneck so again this is sort of hand
wavy let's say I've fixed to that slow
function so in a sense I've removed that
pause as a representation of the
slowness and now when I run the slow
function you see it behaves quite nicely
so this is a way to sort of profile just
within a Wolfram language notebook but
it's not the only thing you can do you
can also profile using our Wolfram
workbench so if you're not familiar with
the workbench it's a
product that works with the Eclipse IDE
and it lets you profile run debuggers
it's really quite handy even lets you
write Wolfram language documentation
pages that look as if they came from our
product so I'll only mention this now
but if you really are sort of a hardcore
developer the workbench might be an
ideal environment for you to develop
your code personally for my smaller
projects I use just the package editor
which is directly part of Mathematica
but again if you're more into text
editors that have a lot of nice features
the Eclipse IDE with the workbench
plug-in is very nice so that is the
conclusion of the first part of this
sort of three-part talk I'll open it up
to questions at the end of each of my
talks I have this sort of glossary and
references the glossary itself if you
click on any one of these it'll jump
back to the point where they were first
mentioned and then the references that I
have further down are just nice internal
guide pages so in documentation guide
pages tutorials this is the video I
mentioned about using our compiler
function and at the same link I have to
the Wolfram workbench plugin so if there
any questions I'll take maybe about five
minutes to answer questions before we
move on to the next section maybe there
are some questions that our organizers
have flagged me to answer so I see that
one question going back to this idea of
having missing data one of the questions
seems like it would be a bummer to you
know say get sensor data with a bunch of
missing values and then it couldn't
become a packed array well in that sense
you just need to do some data cleanup so
if I actually had something that was
missing I'll make this bigger so we can
all see it so there's actually a very
nice function now called delete missing
which will just remove anything that has
a missing head in it so if you do some
data cleanup like this you can then
convert the result into a packed array
another comment about our package format
so the dot WL for Wolfram language or
dot wls for Wolfram language script so
you sort of might have seen that here as
well and one of the participants has
also noted that these work very well
because they're simple text files that
they're easy to DIF and managed through
git which I agree with I do that and we
actually do that internally as well in
the company so another question about
the Eclipse workbench that I mentioned
is the Eclipse bench integration part of
Mathematica how can I install it if you
actually follow the link that I've
presented I guess I opened it up a
second time so this describes the
product and there's this nice big red
button here everyone likes to push big
red buttons this will actually take you
to a very nice guide in how to install
it what's necessary to use it
a very nice installation guide so
hopefully that takes some of the pain
out of switching over to the Eclipse IDE
so now that we've covered how to speed
up a single kernel calculation now we're
gonna talk about using multiple Wolfram
language kernels and so we'll get to
talk about some of these fundamental
concepts so the Wolfram kernel sort of
used behind the scenes if you use this
notebook interface is really the engine
that drives all the computation and so I
need to define a couple of terms just so
we sort of know how that kernel works at
least on an abstract level and then
we'll get into how we can use multiple
kernels a couple of new ways that using
kernels has been introduced this called
task framework and then we'll get into
the more classical parallel
functionality we're actually going to
focus on just using local kernels for
this talk
and a little bit in using remote colonel
connections either the grid Mathematica
product or direct remote connections so
how parallel computation is sort of
architectured in the Wolfram language is
the hub-and-spoke model so what this
picture represents is the center spiky
icon represents a controlling process so
basically the process that you use when
you start out the Mathematica session
and all of these circled spiky icons
indicate sub processes and you see that
as this picture indicates the sub
processes have no communication with
each other they all have to communicate
through the controlling process and then
the controlling process sends any
necessary
signals back out to the sub kernels the
way that these kernels communicate with
each other is through the Wolfram
symbolic transfer protocol or W STP for
short if you've been with our product
for a while you might recall this had
also been called math link and it's
actually the same protocol that's used
to communicate from the notebook
interface to the Wolfram kernel that
same protocol is used to communicate
kernel to kernel or even kernel to
external programs written in C or other
languages so just to get us all on the
same page the types of processes that
occur when you start at the kernel or
front end session like the Mathematica
or Wolfram desktop you have so-called
controlling front ends and controlling
kernels so these are the two you're
probably most familiar with simply
because these are what happened when you
start Mathematica or Wolfram desktop the
controlling front end is the notebook
interface like this presentation and
then every time you put a computation in
like 2+2 and do shift enter to evaluate
then that computation is running on the
controlling kernel
so there are subordinate processes and
that's what we're gonna sort of focus on
in this talk which we like to call sub
kernels and sub front-ends sub kernels
are the ones that we are really going to
focus on
they are always launched as a child
process of the controlling kernel
communication via WS TP you can't run a
sub kernel by itself even if you try
it'll just shut itself down if you try
and launch it as an isolated event and
if you want to know how many licenses
are sorry how many license seats you
have available to you if you look at
your password you can actually read it
directly in your password so if you're
not familiar with where your password is
stored you could do system open of
dollar sign password file and that'll
actually open up
I'll choose notepad so that'll open up
the file that has your password
information in it now I was actually
communicating with a licensed managed
server so in general if you are a single
use activation key for Mathematica or
roll from desktop you'll see something
that looks has a structure like this and
what you really want to look for is
these pairs of numbers here where the
ones that I have highlighted in magenta
indicate the number of controlling
processes front-ends and kernels and
then secondarily the sub processes so
sub kernels and sub front-ends so this
is what you're limited by you can't
launch any more than what your license
allows if you want to use more than
what's listed here then you'll need to
communicate with your Wolfram Sales
Representative in order to pay for more
license seats so why licensing is so
important I would say about 20% of the
errors that will from tech support gets
based on using parallel processes is due
to licensing failures not failure in the
sense that our license technology
is broken down but in the sense that you
don't have access to the license you
think you do
so whenever a colonel launches either a
sub Colonel or controlling Colonel it
looks at that license file to see
whether or not there's a seat available
now you can actually have this file in
many locations and Mathematica will
actually check different locations for
this licensing file so two of the main
locations it looks in is the so called
user based directory and the base
directory and you can also access these
using the system open function and there
is a licensing subfolder and that's
where at least in my case I have a math
pass file stored which contains the
license information so the reason the
base directory I prefer is because this
is independent of user so anyone else
who logs into your machine could open
Mathematica and launch kernels but if
you put your license in the user base
directory only you your user account can
launch those kernels so this can
actually lead to some confusion say like
in an academic setting in a large say
computing lab the installer might have
put things into the user base directory
instead of the base directory and it
looks like you haven't properly licensed
them but you just need to move its
location and everything will be good so
if you're following this talk using one
of our Wolfram desktop products I just
want to let you know that you might not
get as much out of this section simply
because you can't follow along with me
and interact with the provided notebooks
that's because Wolfram desktop products
don't currently allow sub kernel
processes you're only allowed a single
kernel it's partly tied to the fact that
you have to log in with a Wolfram ID and
there's talks in moving to a more
multiple kernel approach for the desktop
products but as it is for now you're
stuck with a single kernel the single
controlling kernel
so one of the things that's also nice if
you're working in a larger organization
is that as a user you don't have to
think about the licensing because the
system administrator has already taken
care of that like in a cluster
environment another thing that comes up
in terms of licensing is people want to
sometimes use kernels on a graphics
processing unit and there's a bit of
confusion they think they need to
install the kernel on every core of the
GPU and that's not true
instead the kernel accesses the entire
GPU through our CUDA link technology or
OpenCL link and you don't need any
additional licensing to use the GPU
other places GPUs are used is in our
machine learning or neural networks
functionality but that's beyond the
scope of this talk so again any other
questions about licensing either talk to
a sales associate or the tech support so
now that we have an understanding of why
why kernels need to be licensed and
where that licensing information comes
from this picture is sort of a graphical
overview of using kernels in a sort of
ad-hoc cluster environment so this
middle one represents your current front
end session you might have a couple of
local kernels represented by these icons
the spiky icons and circles and you
might have some kind of communication
protocol with other sort of just idle
computers laptops etc and you can use
kernels on these remote systems Before
we jump into using these sort of remote
setups let's first focus on using local
kernels first the reason is if again
you're not using say the Wolfram desktop
you can follow along with me learn
everything you need to know about our
parallel functionality and then we'll
come back and see how we can add
external kernels to our computations
so I'll minimize this so I have access
to the menu so if you go to the
evaluation menu and go to parallel
kernel configuration it'll bring up our
Preferences menu and I'll try and make
this a little bigger so it's easier to
see so you'll see a number of tabs sort
of halfway down this preferences menu
we're gonna be focusing on the local
kernels section of this so what a local
kernel is one that resides on the
computer that you're working at you're
sitting at and Mathematica automatically
detects how many CPU cores you have on
that machine in order to launch some
local kernels so in my case mathematic
is automatically detected that I have
four physical CPU cores now there is
hyper threading technology either
Intel's or other chips they have sort of
versions of this these are logical
divisions of the physical CPU core we
don't recommend running on them not
because you can't but you might not get
as much performance out of it because as
logical CPUs go the operating system has
to basically determine how to divide the
different threads up so just to be sort
of more robust just use the physical CPU
cores that Mathematica detects I'm not
saying that you can't override this
detection in this menu setting if you
switch to manual you can then have as
many kernels launch as you want with the
restriction of Licensing of course so
that's always at your disposal so one of
the ways that you can use a local
one-off task so the something that sort
of spins up a kernel and dies is sort of
this new task framework I won't go into
a lot of detail but if I submit
something that submits very quickly
using session submit it runs with
all of the knowledge that we have on the
existing controlling Colonel and then
once it finishes with its calculation
it'll come back with a result so this is
nice to just do a one-off task you have
some idea you want to run but you don't
want to inhibit your current use of the
front end other things that you can do
is local submit now this will actually
spin up a new sub colonel so this
session submit actually runs on a
different W STP connection but it
doesn't have to start anything else
local submit starts a local sub colonel
to do the calculation and there it is
so you see it took a little bit of time
to spin up and now it eventually
returned the result I'm choosing to have
everything returned as a message dialog
just for this example and then we also
have cloud submit so if you're connected
to the Wolfram cloud if you do a cloud
submission this will spin up pay
connection to the cloud and you see the
connection was successful and then after
we wait for a while it'll also return
from the cloud well sort of disappeared
pretty quickly here we go
and so you see we get the same message
dialog returned to us with the correct
calculation done so this is just a way
to sort of asynchronously do
calculations on separate processes
either on the cloud or locally but again
these are intended to be one-off tasks
or if you use the scheduled task
framework you can schedule when you want
these to run but this is beyond the
scope of our discussion today so let's
get back into the basics of using
parallel kernels in our hub-and-spoke
model so the easiest way to get started
is either using launch kernels with an
empty set of arguments or in my case I'm
telling my local system to launch two
sub kernels and you see I get these back
if you want to know how many kernels you
currently have running I could ask for
kernels Oh looks like I had already
started one up remotely
and then when you're all done with the
kernels you can close them manually
using the close kernels function so
there are a number of functions that
start with the parallel word so parallel
array combined etc I won't go into all
of them specifically but I will sort of
touch on how they work so you notice
that I have closed all of my kernels if
you start a parallel process without
kernels available you they will get a
warning like so or you can launch some
kernels if I hadn't already launched
kernels then this would have spun up the
available kernels automatically so for
simple operations like this due to
overhead of communication you won't
notice an actual speed-up and that's one
of the main sort of gotchas is that the
overhead is somewhat significant but
I'll explain how we can try and minimize
that so when you're using the W STP
protocol in this communication between
kernels you want to minimize the
overhead of the communication so you
actually want to send a minimal amount
of information to each kernel the other
thing to keep in mind is that each
kernel is sort of an independent entity
will duplicate any memory that you need
it to access so if you have a large
matrix for example and you send it to
another kernel because you want it to
compute on just one of the rows of that
matrix don't send the entire matrix just
send the row so really minimize the
amount of may data that you're sending
back and forth so because of this
hub-and-spoke model the types of
problems that are most amenable to our
parallelization scheme is the sort of
embarrassingly parallel izybelle problem
it's the one that is completely
independent of other runs of that code
so for example I have a numerical
integration that takes a somewhat long
amount of time in this case roughly a
second so if I were to do this just on a
single core this should take a little
bit over 10 seconds to run I guess it
must have cached a few things so how we
first get this distributed to all of the
sub kernels they're not aware of this
function I've defined right away so we
should first distribute that definition
that's symbol and once we've done the
distribution we can then run these in
parallel such as say through parallel
table and you see that because I have
four kernels currently running
I got roughly not quite the theoretical
maximum but I got a little less than a
factor of four speed-up because these
are truly operations that are completely
independent of each other
so I'm gonna talk about a few concepts
that are not unique to the Wolfram
language one of them is memory
management so I already hinted that if
you want a computation to occur on a sub
kernel
it already has to have the data local to
that sub kernel and so it's up to you
the programmer to try and make sure all
of the data is synchronous there are
some things you can do but it really the
onus is on you to sort of know what the
current state of each of these kernels
is in you can directly evaluate on a sub
kernel using the parallel evaluate
function but be careful if you do this
because you can get these kernels to
become out of sync with each other so
for example if I evaluate or set the
symbol value k equal to 3 I can then
separately set that which I'm going to
go ahead and quit the kernel so all of
my kernels are numbered from 1 to an
onward again okay so now I'm gonna set
the global variable K to 3 and then I'm
going to spin up a couple of kernels you
see this is happening automatically
because I haven't launched any kernels
yet once my four local kernels launch
you then see that I'm saying that kernel
one should reset the value of k2 for
kernel two should reset the value to
five and then when I ask for those three
values you see that they're now
different on each kernel so if I were to
do something like parallel evaluate oops
missed parallel
you'll see that I get different results
depending on which Colonel is doing the
evaluation so this can get kind of
confusing especially when you use
functions like parallel do so make sure
you have in mind your sort of data
synchronicity when you're doing these
parallel computations you can use shared
variables using the function set shared
variable but this is only useful if you
access that variable in frequently if
you're changing that value every single
time like in a table or a do loop then
you're going to be swamped by the
overhead of updating that variable
because this is the hub-and-spoke model
every time one of the sub kernels
changes it has to tell the master the
controlling kernel then has to
distribute that change to all the sub
kernels and if they have already
subsequently changed they have to
communicate over and over and over again
just to make sure that this variable is
synchronized between all the sub kernels
so really use this one with care only
with variables that are updated in
frequently so another sort of concept
that is beyond our not exclusive to the
Wolfram language is the concept of
course versus fine-grained
parallelization it's also known as load
balancing so if I were to use a function
like parallel do it defaults to coarse
grained parallelization so I'm gonna
actually quit the kernel again just so I
can have this work the way I want so
let's say we have this sort of abstract
task so I have it listed here just
abstractly pause statements representing
something that takes a long time to run
so if I launch exactly two kernels to
local kernels when I use a function like
parallel do this is saying that if the
iterator is less than three I'm gonna
have the
computation otherwise I'll use the
shorter computation if I look at this
the course grained approach is actually
splitting it up it takes the iterator
itself which is this list of values and
because I'm using two kernels divides it
exactly in half so the reason this whole
process took eight seconds is because
the first kernel is getting hit with all
of the long-running calculations and the
second kernel got the fast ones or short
running ones so you can change this by
using the finest grained method so it's
the exact same computation I've only
changed the method and now what happens
is it basically goes through the list
and changes which kernel gets each
operation so now you see this only takes
five seconds because each kernel got
roughly the same amount of work so there
is a question it's very common question
is there any way to make the kernels
communicate to each other directly
instead of communicate through the
master kernel so that it's funny because
the short answer is no the long answer
is yes but the reason that it seems like
a contradiction is because the
documented approach the one that's
supported with our lovely tech support
team does not allow communication this
automatic communication outside of the
hub-and-spoke approach however if you
are a wost pea guru you can communicate
between sub kernels using the W STP
protocol but you have to set up your own
links between them but we won't that's
definitely beyond the scope of this talk
so getting back to sort of this load
balancing idea there is another approach
we can take which is called parallel
submit this effectively creates your own
computation queue it's very similar to
finest grained so I'm using the table
function the reason with is here is just
I want to inject the value and create
different sort of abstract computations
so you see pause again
is a representation of long-running
processes and you see it's quite random
so I have ten sort of randomly long
processes so this is both difficult for
the coarsest crane to do and might be
difficult for finest grained in order to
properly load balance but using this
computation queue and using the weight
all function I'm only using two kernels
right now and so you see the kernel that
first becomes available grabs the next
one in line so if you have a bunch of
short processes together one of the
kernels might just take all of them
because it gets through them quicker but
this is a very nice representation of
having your own computation queue so one
of the things we like to do with this
company is make everything sort of easy
we want to sort of take away the
difficulty of some of these concepts
from the user and just have everything
work but let's say you're a little bit
more nit picking and you want to see
what's going on under the hood
in our parallel framework you can do
that so if you load the parallel package
it has a function called traceurs which
will sort of show some of the
communication over W STP one of the ones
that's kind of neat to see a send
receive so what this is going to do is
show anytime communication occurs
between the master and the sub kernels
we're gonna see a message pop up another
thing to note that the global context is
rather unique and these demonstrations
will show how so let's say I define a
global variable if I evaluate this on
just the first kernel these first two
send receive messages are basically
saying hey something has changed on the
global context we need to send that
information to all of the sub kernels
then you see that the sub kernels tell
the controlling kernel hey we've got
that message everything is ready to go
then the parallel evaluation takes place
so first we sort of have data
synchronicity with the global context
and then we send the global there to the
sub kernel and you see it evaluates
directly on that sub kernel but it knows
what that value is because sort of
behind the scenes it was updated for us
before so this is just unique to the
global variable or the sorry the global
context if we have a function that lives
or variable that lives in some other
context and we repeat the same process
you see that there is no pre
communication it just said hey sub
kernel one what is this value and sub
kernel one says I don't know because you
didn't tell me and so it returns
unevaluated and then you might ask well
then why do we still get the number two
that's because in our effort to make
things sort of effortless for the user
we silently returned this symbol and the
master kernel then evaluates it so this
can sort of the reason I like this way
of debugging is otherwise you'll get
these silent returns that looks like
things are working correctly where in
reality things are actually being done
sequentially they're not actually being
done in parallel and so if you ever see
a symbol get sent to a kernel and
returned unevaluated you know that that
definition is missing on that sub kernel
process so as you get more into software
development you might start developing
your own packages now package
development again there's a separate
course you can sign up for it's beyond
the scope of this talk but you'll create
these packages that you want to use and
maybe the definitions you put into these
packages will be useful to be run in
parallel in that case once you have the
package you'll need to use the parallel
needs
action to let all of the sub kernels
know to use those definitions so as an
example I'm gonna create a very basic
package very very basic and I'm gonna go
ahead and store it in the base directory
so everyone has all users have access to
that package once it's there I can call
needs to get those definitions they're
just very simple addition and
multiplication in order that my sub
kernels also know about it I need to do
parallel needs and once I do that you
see that some communication has occurred
the sub kernels are gaining knowledge
about what's in that package and then if
I call one of those functions that lives
in the package you'll see that it was
evaluated directly on the sub kernel
public two returns eight and then that
value of eight is sent back to the
master so this is handy but you need to
be careful once we move to a distributed
sort of mindset where these packages
live you might not have access to the
remote computing systems there the
memory and the storage that you do
locally in that case because the sub
kernels need to grab that package from
somewhere one of these sort of
workarounds is to just use distribute
definitions because you can distribute
entire contexts so if I use distribute
definitions of this context it also
sends those definitions to all the sub
kernels including the private
definitions without the need to put this
package copy it to the remote computers
locations this will just use W STP to
send the definitions so now that we sort
of know how parallelization works at
least sort of a very rough introduction
to it let's talk about where other
kernels can come from one of the places
kernels could live is remotely and you
can just use remote kernels to access
them now these are sort of tricky to set
up and this is external to the Wolfram
language but I'll sort of walk through
this window system and
munication with the linux computer so
technically any Mathematica installation
can provide you with Mathematica kernels
even ones that live remotely the thing
that really hampers this approach is
most often firewalls I would say 80% of
the time there is some kind of network
issue between you locally and a remote
server other things to keep in mind is
that if you're using clusters for
example you might actually be charged by
the hour or they're not even available
for public use so these are things to
consider if you're trying to connect to
a remote machine so I'm gonna go quickly
through a couple of error messages you
might see I don't really want to focus
on sort of error issues but just to give
you an idea of why this is sort of
technically challenging and it's
definitely outside of Wolfram technology
stack these are just generic networking
issues that your local system
administrator might be able to help you
with so the first thing to check if
you're trying to talk to a remote
computer is can you reach it and so you
can use for example the ping function
and if it comes back that it could not
find it mathematic is not going to you
know find it if it you yeah so this is
just a system setting or you might ping
it and the transmission failed for some
error again Mathematica is not going to
succeed if this doesn't succeed another
thing you might run into if you're using
the SSH protocol for communication first
you need to check if it works outside of
Mathematica so if you first SSH to a
machine that you've never talked to
before it'll ask you about this RSA
fingerprint and so if this if you've not
talked to the Machine outside of
Mathematica mathematical actually hang
on this issue so it's usually good to
SSH to each computer first another issue
is if you put in the wrong password
mathematic is not going to successfully
connect if you get the password wrong
another issue is just you have a very
slow connection to the machine so if the
connection times out then mathematic is
not going to succeed and if there's a
firewall in the way if the connection it
was just flatly refused you're not going
to succeed so let's say we've already
completed and fixed all of those errors
now all you need to know that
Mathematica is installed on each
computer so if you log in to that
computer and run the math command this
is assuming you're on Linux and it comes
back and says that commands not found
then you need to figure out where
Mathematica is installed if it is at all
or if it comes back that you get access
to the kernel but it can't find a valid
password again you need to resolve this
issue
normally by licensing within the base
directory but so these are just sort of
baby steps towards making this
connection possible so one of the ways
that I do this from a Windows machine is
I use a very small function called putty
and you want to make sure that it's
actually on your computer's path so the
reason for this is Mathematica will need
to access this program and the easiest
way to access it is just to have it on
the path so you can just call it without
needing to know where its exact location
is so I'm gonna go ahead and put in my
password
so I'm going to use the run process
function and P link putty link is part
of the putty package and it was
successful I'm directly putting in my
password although you can't see it and
what this does is it just returns what I
would expect it's a listing of the
location that I asked for so now this is
a very solid check that I can make a
remote connection because there is a
computer I'm trying to log into and I
can successfully access it using the SSH
protocol which is what plink uses so now
that I know that it works one of the
things that we recommend though is using
public private keys so you don't have to
put in such a password and so one of the
programs that I use which again is part
of this sort of low low level putty
system is Oh pageant's already running
so what Pageant allows you to do is
actually load keys so again public
private keys beyond the scope of this
talk your system administrator might be
able to help you with this but now you
see I don't have the password field
anymore but it's the exact same command
and so you see the public private keys
take care of the whole password
authentication so all of this all of
these remote processes can also be taken
care of in the preferences parallel
configuration menu under the remote
kernels tab you can actually indicate
which hosts you want to go through you
can even set up the launch command
directly so Windows defaults to SSH but
I'll show you how we can change that you
can also turn on the same kind of
tracers
so unlike the send/receive tracer we can
turn on the math link tracer and that'll
tell you what math link is doing under
the hood but in practice it's actually
is helpful than you might think
oftentimes you'll just get some kind of
connection generic message so let's
continue with this example of connecting
to remote kernels so I'm going to go
ahead and do this on the low level aside
by loading the sub kernels package and
what this gives us access to is the
remote command so this is the same thing
that we see in this parallel connection
dialog and so I'm going to go ahead and
change that instead to use this blink
program that's external to Mathematica
now these everything else is the same
I'm just basically saying use this in
order to basically utilize the SSH
protocol and then I can use launch
kernels like I did for local machines
now I'm going to do it for remote
machines and you see I get my kernel
object back so the connection was
successful so I know I made it look like
it worked but that's because I went
through the effort of making sure all of
the firewalls were open and other such
nuisances I'm actually gonna turn this
on real quick I'll just show you what
happens with math link turned on so I'm
gonna go ahead and launch another kernel
and so now we get more printouts and so
you see it's opening something up now
the thing I want you to notice is that
the math link that was created is
created on a certain port so even though
we're using SSH which is port 22 to
establish the connection the Mathematica
W STP protocol occurs on any port
greater than like 30,000 that scans for
an open port number and makes the
connection through that so this is where
some confusion occurs if you have a
firewall you effectively need to open it
up
above a certain range of values
otherwise the send/receive communication
will fail and actually the kernel will
probably refuse to launch if there was
some firewall in the way so another way
to access remote kernels is through our
grid Mathematica product I won't go into
as much detail about this it's
effectively Mathematica just without the
documentation but it also includes an
Apache Tomcat server which allows you to
communicate through a different
mechanism than SSH so what I like about
Grid Mathematica is that it can be
installed because it's like Mathematica
on any operating system you don't hand
it'll use its own protocol to
communicate between them so if you don't
want to go through the rigmarole of this
SSH setup you still have to consider
which ports are open there's a very nice
that doesn't very well so we have an
again a nice support article that
teaches you how to set up grid
Mathematica how to install it if you
have access to this product in general
you just install it on every machine it
can live side by side with existing
Mathematica installations but in general
I talked to our tech support people if
you want to know more about it or sales
rep if you're interested in this product
it is also part of the Preferences menu
so if you click on the lightweight grid
tab and then click enable lightweight
grid you will notice that it'll take a
while to get started that's because it's
already scanning for local servers can
you see that we do have a local server
setup and if you click on that local
server you can even jump to the webpage
that manages those processes but again
this is sort of beyond the scope of the
talk but it's another way
to access remote kernels okay so now
we're going to talk specifically about
cluster environments so just to recap
where we've come we know how to optimize
on a single process a single kernel we
now know how to access basic parallel
functionality and we sort of have an
idea of how we can talk to remote
kernels so the this builds on that the
previous ones in the sense that a
cluster environment is just a larger
environment with more kernels involved
so if you're in academia or a government
institution you might already have
access to a large computing facility
installing Mathematica is really up to
the cluster manager the cluster
administrator but if you're interested
well this the there are other options
available to you if you aren't part of a
large organization that's more generally
about cloud computing which I'm actually
not covering in this talk either
AWS Azure or actually one of our current
partners rescale so you basically pay by
the hour
but it's axed anyone who has the
financial resources can access that so
we already could talk to clusters for
quite a while now using our cluster
integration package but the cluster
technology is sort of outpaced our
upkeep of that integration the cluster
integration package so I'm going to show
you how sort of a modern cluster
approach works and then I know I'm
already short on time but I'll try and
show basically a standard way of
communicating to make sure that we're
all on the same page because I know not
everybody has done cluster computing
before this diagram is sort of a rough
idea of what a cluster would look like
you have a bunch of computers that are
all networked together and the network
itself is connected to a so called head
node which acts as a gateway into this
computer system
the headnote most likely has the
firewall to protect outside intruders
from accessing the compute nodes but
generally speaking the compute nodes
have free communication between each
other so normally you would connect your
workstation it might be a sort of lower
level powerful laptop and so you would
connect either through Wi-Fi or Ethernet
to this head node and talk to the head
nodes submit your jobs and then those
will get distributed to the system so
generically how we use one of these
systems with Mathematica so oftentimes
you'll use SSH because most clusters are
Linux based clusters and so you would
SSH to the head node and put in your
password and then once you're on the
head node you would use some kind of
submission program to submit your job to
the head node now I have a sort of vague
representation of what your job looks
like it's just a sequence of commands
the hash structure so again this is
beyond the scope of the talk in the
sense that the Wolfram language part of
it
I will go over in more detail but if you
want to learn how to use clusters and
sort of the scripting language it's
really not a Wolfram technology so it
will take a little bit of time to get up
to speed but to try and get us all in
the same page I'll explain this sort of
short snippet the first line is just
indicating which program the script is
running through the second line here is
telling the cluster manager so the
actual program that oversees the cluster
the software program it's basically
telling it I want to launch five I want
five nodes all to myself most systems
have some kind of modular approach to
the applications you have access to and
so you might use something like a module
loader to load Mathematica and then once
Mathematica is loaded you would just use
it like you would
any command-line environment using math
and a script with a package so once you
submit a job though it has to wait in a
queue you're not the only one accessing
these modern computation sources anymore
so you have to be patient the job has to
run on its own without any monitoring of
you know looking over its shoulder and
once you wait your turn you eventually
get to the top of the queue and once you
get through the queue the cluster
manager then gives you the resources
you've requested and so in this case I
asked for five nodes exclusively to
myself these are colored in green and
then the cluster manager just reads line
by line the other parts that are in your
script so in this case we're starting up
Mathematica as indicated by an icon the
math spikey and then the script itself
the Mathematica Wolfram language script
might spin up additional parallel sub
kernels and utilize them in parallel and
that's using all of the same
functionality that we've seen before
using the remote kernels using SSH to
talk to each other etc so then once the
job has finished all of the resources
are given back to the cluster and then
you can do everything again so that's
generically how you would use
Mathematica in a modern cluster
environment abstractly speaking you can
still use a so-called interactive
session this is very similar to what I
just described except you need to use
some kind of X Windows forwarding the
job you indicate is specifically an
interactive job you have to wait through
the queue but you notice that when you
submit an interactive job you don't get
direct access back to the cluster you
sort of have to wait but once you get
through then you actually are
effectively running your job as if you
had logged into that computing resource
directly so in that sense you might run
Mathematica indicated again by the icon
and then because this is an a Windows
system or a windowing system you get the
Mathematica front-end sent back to you
now this is where the pros and cons the
trade-off here you have to consider
because even though things are being
displayed on your local laptop for
example all of your keystrokes are being
sent through the network to this remote
computer it does the calculation and
sends the visual result back to you so
this can be quite slow depending on how
the speeds of your network are this
mathematica session might you know spin
up some sub kernels and then once
everything is done you should exit your
session to return all of the resources
back to the cluster so just briefly we
did have a we still have a cluster
integration package the reason this is
sort of no longer encouraged to use is
whenever you requested a sub kernel
through this method every sub kernel you
asked for was a separate submission to
the clusters queue and because they're
now have many many users on them you
might wait for a very long time to get
that sub kernel to actually start
running furthermore only a subset of
clusters and not all of these are even
supported anymore or even exists they
might have been end-of-life so really we
take a more modern approach let the
cluster do its own thing and just run
Mathematica on that cluster so if you
need we do have another support article
that tells you in a little bit more
detail than what I've gone over in this
talk about how to use Mathematica in
such a cluster environment but really
the main assumptions is that you have
free communication so password list
communication between all of the compute
nodes and Mathematica has the same
executable on every single file system
generally that's not an issue because
they used cloned file systems
but just keep in mind that that is a
requirement so we've already seen sort
of a generic version of the submission
script the main things to notice is how
many resources you're asking for how
long you intend to run the job and then
you simply just run Mathematica as a
scripted file so this looks a bit
complicated but it's really not as
different as you might think
so let's Fergus focus on just the first
part here so every cluster is different
and the approach that we take now is
letting the cluster you know do its own
thing and just asking querying the
cluster for the relevant information so
specifically for the slurm cluster
manager so the simple Linux cluster
manager again your system administrator
could probably help you know what things
to ask for but you basically s control
as a function that is known to the
cluster the slurm cluster manager and
this is basically saying I want to know
all of the jobs basically every
computation node that was supplied to me
during my request I want to know what
those are the slurm one is a bit
trickier because you have to parse what
it returns to you with this basically
says two nodes were given to you and
then one kernel perd to more nodes we're
provided so I don't want to again go
through the details of this but
basically once you know the names of the
computers that are provided to you and
how many CPU cores were provided per
node everything else is the same that
we've seen before we have a simple
remote kernels command we manually load
the sub kernels package and then we
simply use launch kernels using SSH to
launch the kernels on every single node
so it's a bit more manual setup
but it's a more modern approach to using
Mathematica on a cluster once this is
done you just use all of the same
parallel functions that you would in a
normal Mathematica script making sure to
save any results you need to an external
file so I've gone ahead and done this
before we even set up a toy cluster here
at Wolfram so I need I don't need X 1114
so I'm using putty again just to set up
this connection and I'm gonna make it a
little easier for us to see bumping up
the font so this is mimicking as if I
have logged into a head node of a
cluster and once you're in the head node
so as my login name is Wolfram I can see
what I have in my home directory and I
have a couple of test job scripts I've
already written the one that we're gonna
look at in particular is the math job
here this should look very similar to
what I just showed in the Mathematica
notebook the only additional things I'm
doing I'm only asking for one node but
again I'm just running a simple
mathematical script and then making sure
to save my results to the current
working directory and the Mathematica
script that I'm running on slurm this is
identical to what you just saw in the
code cell previously so I'm not going to
go into too much detail here I did add
additional sort of debugging I added the
Mathematica math link tracers for
example but otherwise it's the same
script so on slurm we have the s batch
command and so I will actually just
submit the math job and if I'm quick
enough I can actually see it in the
queue so you see the job 71
as it's currently running under my
username Wolfram yeah by the time I
asked for this it had been running for
two seconds and it also tells you how
many are which resources it's running on
and if I look at the queue again you see
it's already done because this is a very
fast process and then I see I actually
have the result back because I asked to
save this result so if I look at I think
I can just get the result so this is
just indicating this is basically
HelloWorld on a cluster using
Mathematica I asked each kernel to tell
me where it was located and what its
local ID number was and so you see this
was able to launch eight kernels on wtg
cluster one so I'll leave this up in
case there's any questions about this
aspect but in general this is as far as
I wanted to get today and I appreciate
your patience we did run a little bit
over this same process is also can be
done on other cluster manager systems
such as torque the commands might be a
slightly different again you'll need to
sort of research that on your own but
the torque one is similar all of these
commands down here are exactly the same
it's just a little bit easier to parse
for the available resources that were
provided but in any case if you have any
other questions I'd be happy to answer
them so I did anticipate this question
so I'm glad you asked how do we
distribute big data files over a cluster
strictly speaking that's beyond the
scope of this talk I wasn't intending to
talk about big data I was mostly focused
on speed and using kernels in
distributed environments it's not
impossible to distribute big data in
general you might use an external pro
Grahame such as hadoop to do these kind
of big data things if mathematic is
installed you can access it I think I
will just actually stop my explanation
there that's beyond the scope of this
talk unless you meant something else by
distributing big data because recall I
did talk about memory management in the
Khans
in the scope of using kernels because
each kernel would be actually gonna go
back to my main diagram so let's say the
kernels are you have access to a cluster
like this a big memory cluster assuming
that the files you want to process
already exist on each of the the nodes
then all you need to do is spin up a
kernel like I just demonstrated use the
Mathematica functionality to access the
local file system so you can actually so
you can use things like file names or
other file type functions to access the
local file structure of the local
compute clusters but any this is a bit
more involved